oh so why
do you think that they look somewhat
like us that they're hominid that they
have two eyes that they have too
you know there's something called
convergent evolution but it's not as if
all intelligent species must converge
to be like us so i'm curious why do you
think it is that they look
similar to us i don't mean to be coy but
i don't know that they do
and the reason is when you first start
looking into ufos you get all these
ideas
you're like they must be from other
planets
why are they visiting here that's like
you know ufos 101 the first thought you
got
then you're like oh they've been
represented to look kind of hominid you
know
whatever bipedal creatures the more you
look into this
the more you realize all of that is is
uh not
supported with the evidence it turns out
we don't know
if these craft are from other solar
systems
or if they're if it's stranger than that
if it's a dimensional
reality if these things are popping in
and out somehow
of of our demand into our dimension we
don't know we are so far behind in
understanding
certainly hard physical craft makes you
think they're from other planets
for sure could be maybe they're looking
at us
like they would um livestock like a
commodity
maybe they have some investment in the
human species for some reason
and this is why they show or flex on the
powers of our nuclear weapons which
they've done a lot
additionally the other thing what do you
mean when you say that you mean that
when
we have done nuclear tests the ufo
sightings have increased
so there's a lot of uh information and
evidence
of the ufo phenomenon engaging
our nuclear process so everything from
coming into very famous cases like i
mentioned before
male storm in maelstrom air force base
there is a ufo a disc that came in and
shot
a beam of light down into the nuclear
silo and again don't believe me this is
documented fact this came out through
foia this came out through information
acts
and it shut down our nuclear weapons it
was a display of
power so why are they doing that right
and they're not only doing it to us
there's also documented cases in russia
at the same time
at the height of the cold war so
obviously there's some sort of
message being sent where these whoever
is occupying these craft whoever is
piloting
these craft whether it be a physical
being
or an artificial intelligence whatever's
piloting these vehicles
they're they're showing us hey we can
shut down your nukes
at any time so i would suggest everybody
look into that so you don't just look at
this guy and say oh crazy guy told me
this
look into it this is something that is
verifiable fact
and if any if sorry if any of you who
are listening
are somewhat specialized in the ufo
field if you don't mind
putting some of the sources because i
can't get to them all that'd be great
and then i can link them in the
description
okay continue yeah and then i just want
to touch upon what you said
because we're going through this this
zeitgeist of like what ufos are so
people are like oh they're from other
planets
i am unconvinced the more i learn i'm
unconvinced this is a phenomenon of just
other people from other star systems
coming here it
the evidence does not suggest that when
you really look at the totality of the
evidence
it's not just flying saucers shaped or
saucers we have all shapes and sizes of
vehicles that shouldn't be existing in
our skies
again commander fravor chased a
tic-tac-shaped ufo
there's a very famous case called the
phoenix lights and this is a mass
sighting of a triangular shaped craft
like a mile wide we don't have anything
like that in our arsenal
and people that you speak with who
actually saw it i interviewed a doctor
and a lawyer husband and wife
who who saw it and this this thing came
over it touched mountain to mountain
so it was over a mile wide and when it
came over them totally silent
it was like as if there was a bubble
around them of silence like all the
crickets stopped everything
and they're looking at what would have
been the bottom of this thing and it
looks like
waving of glass like they can see the
stars through it
and there's a lot of reasons you know
that you can see different
optics when you when you see these craft
because of how they're powered
how they distort how they navigate is
through a propulsion system based on
gravity as we know gravity
distorts time and space so you can get
an optical illusion just looking up at
these things
back to the beings because this is
always exciting people will say well
they look like us they're bipedal no
that's not true there are so many cases
of the grays
right that's what you're referring to
this popularization
of the gray alien and yeah a lot of
people have seen that betty and barney
hill
were the first abduction case to
identify
this type of being in the pop culture
however
there's been a lot of reports of
different types of
operators of these craft they look very
different than that
so i can't say for sure that we're being
visited by another planet
i can't say for sure that these things
look a certain way
again these could be artificial cyborg
intelligences
that are just uh being controlled by a
super intelligent ai we don't know
who's controlling and piloting these
craft they could be drones
when you say that it's not necessarily
from
outside of our solar system then do you
mean that it's us
in the future or do you mean that it's
when you say another dimension
i'm unclear so let's please speculate
i'm uncle i don't even know what another
dimension means
i'm not that smart i i just know that
the evidence doesn't suggest that this
is just
people from zeta reticuli star system
coming in and visiting us because they
like our mushrooms i mean
i don't know but people have theorized
that these are extra temporal beings by
the nature of time travel itself or by
the nature of gravitational travel
itself you do have
distortions in time and space so some
people say they're extra temporal
they're they're being they're us from
the future
i have no idea the evidence doesn't
suggest that to me